let's focus first on Sunday night chair
cuz we both got it wrong yes and this is
one of those where and I hate this
feeling after the fact I knew it I knew
it I knew it and I refused to let my
brain accept it I knew the Saints were
gonna give him everything they could
have yeah sure but I kept telling myself
man the Cowboys are good the Cowboys are
good look at how good they are both
sides of the ball they have no real
weaknesses yeah they're gonna go in
there and they're gonna dismantle this
Saints team that doesn't have Drew Brees
and what happened well what what
happened I mean first off they're not
just a one-trick pony they're in New
Orleans I mean we've seen this the last
year when Drew Brees struggled down the
stretch last year they don't they've
gotten over the fact of all we need Drew
Brees to throw for 400 yards every game
for us to win no in the last three years
they've become more of a running team
they've been able to play defense they
have a great defensive front it's it's
almost impossible to run the ball on
them and then Sean Payton comes up with
the proper gameplan Dennis Allen looks
like you through a few curveballs at
that Dallas offense that they weren't
expecting and then I think with a lot of
the teams we were talking about we're
correction Sunday like you're saying or
Thursday you know self-inflicted wounds
forth and one fumble by Zeke Elliot you
know Jason Witten catching a ball wide
open over the middle as they're kind of
moving the ball and you go okay here
goes Dallas you know so there was a lot
of issues like that not only with the
Cowboys the Rams the Packers had their
mistakes as well but you know I mean
again I just can't say enough about Sean
Payton I know you respect him the same
way don't you the ear type stuff yes
exactly
and last night without Drew Brees it's
Coach of the Year types I agreed it
really is he just he finds a new way to
play football and he's playing yell a
little more conservative with the pass
game but still running the football and
they're going through their defense
who's really stepped up I mean their
defenses I think what we questions
especially after that Rams game and week
one and even the Texans I mean the Rams
game in week two and the Texas game in
week one they didn't look great and
they're certainly playing good football
guys read it on that driver the Texans
went ahead okay they got so shred that
enough time to win the game right they
should have been shredded so quickly if
they hadn't have been they would have
lost that game but they're now at 3 & 1
will Lutz had four field goals for the
Saints it was the first victory in the
Sean Payton era without a touchdown for
the Saints and the Cowboys had only 40
five yards on the ground they got
bottled up they got stymied Zeke had 35
and a fumble on 18 carries so and I got
a theory about this yeah you know we
talked about the malaise the Saints
would be experiencing after two straight
extremely heartbreaking exits from the
postseason right how do you go back to
zero and zero and how do you dig out and
I almost feel like the drew brees injury
was the slap in the face to snap you out
of whatever funk you may be in like oh
my god like oh the Rams yeah Rams Saints
game the the bad but you know then the
Vikings Minneapolis you you have this
happen with Brees and everybody's got to
go to battle station no questions around
okis on their jobs and again credit the
Sean Payton this is the old Bill
Parcells no excuses for yeah yeah no
excuses for injury
everybody is expected to do their job
Bridgewater and everyone else and we're
gonna go out and we're gonna win games
and it's almost like that did wake them
up yes and how else do you account for
beating their previously undefeated
Seahawks yeah in their building right
and then the previously undefeated
Cowboys in back-to-back weeks well I
mean first off you hit the you hit the
nail on the head I mean Sean Payton
deserves the the the credit here because
he's just a tough psycho coach and he
just expects none you know nothing less
than the best from his team and he
continues to press the right buttons I
mean we heard about things he did last
year motivating the team I'm sure he's
doing things this year I agree with you
with the Drew Brees thing I think at all
a gets everybody kind of on their P's
and Q's cuz you go man there's no room
for error
he's not gonna save us if we're playing
bad but the biggest thing that jumps out
to me about the New Orleans Saints is
their physicality they went up to New
Seattle and out hit Seattle in Seattle
okay that doesn't happen very much and
then just stood there toe-to-toe with
the Dallas Cowboys last night whose is
you know the all get off the bus team
and you know I think a lot of credit
does go to that defensive line you
talked about what they did you know
running the ball the Cowboys are lack of
doing but you know I talked about this
in my podcast last week the Saints
defensive line if you think you're gonna
run between the tackles negative
ghostrider you're not I mean the big
runs they've led up this year have been
on the
edge and things like that you're not
gonna run up the middle they got great
run stoppers across the board and I
showed that again once it once again
last night and one of the reasons why I
wish I would have picked the Saints I
know that Payton was so upset about that
loss last year that really did show some
weaknesses with the Saints and maybe set
the offense back although they did
nearly make it to the Super Bowl but
that was that Thursday night after
Thanksgiving and and I think that he was
still salty about that and the thing to
watch with Payton he gets that blue
steel going on the nights where he's
really locked in all and a blue steel
you can see it under under the headset
yeah yeah you know he's ready when you
see that look his lips perk yeah yeah
totally and it doesn't turn right yeah
he only turns left like a loose deal but
he's but he is he is locked in in this
moment yeah Teddy Bridgewater was locked
in he said the Saints came into the game
with a chip on their shoulder here's
Bridgewater after the game we knew that
I was gonna be a bit of a battle coming
into this game you know last year we
heard about how physical how much more
physical they were than us and we knew
coming to this game that we had to be
the most physical team in Italy we know
how hard it is to win football games and
no one said they had to be pretty Teddy
was 23 of 34 193 yards no touchdowns one
pick five sacks but you know I amazing
story we're three years removed yeah
that devastating knee injury he was
right on the verge of of getting to
whatever his ceiling would have been in
Minnesota who knows what it would have
been working Norv Turner and Mike Zimmer
but now he persevered he didn't play a
whole lot of football and when he did
play it was not overwhelming at the last
two weeks you can't ask for more win the
games it doesn't matter if it's not 300
yards now it doesn't matter if it's not
four touchdowns and no picks you do we
have to do to win the game and that's
what they that's right and they never
had to push the envelope last week in
Seattle because the defense calls Tudor
I mean a turnovers and they had the punt
return touchdown so they never even had
it like unveil the offense in Seattle
last night I don't care if it was drew
Brees John Elway whatever it was gonna
be tough sledding no matter what I mean
that Dallas defense is for real I mean
he was under attack all night long you
could see Dallas can cover on the back
end I mean they got linebackers in it
cover Alvin Kamara and all the
underneath routes that Sean Payton does
designs to them he got lucky with his
interception that was a nice play Ted
Ginn just dropped the football really
but yes Teddy Bridgewater's playing in
the right way managing the game making a
few throws here and there and I mean it
really is a great success story for him
and what he overcame and I'm happy for
him as a human being I really am I mean
they just wanted to go 500 while Drew
Brees was out well now they're 2 and oh
yeah and what we'll see how much longer
breeze is out you can see he was he was
getting that thumb loose throughout the
night doing his little thumb exercise
he's got a brace inside of the thumb and
I think that look when breeze sees the
team winning without him that makes him
even more determined to get back sooner
rather than later because he doesn't
want people like us yeah
to think that we're reasonable people
right I think that they don't need him
yeah well I mean you know again this the
course they need him like it's they're
better football I'm saying I know
exactly what you're saying I gotta make
a decision right right well it's just
another this is more evidence you know
where I get I get sick of this talk
anyways a quarterback quarterback
quarterback quarterback quarterback
quarterback quarterback quarterback
that's the only thing that matters no
you can see hey New England won
yesterday Tom Brady played like crap you
know New Orleans wins again Drew Brees
is in there so it's a team sport I'm
just sick of us giving the quarterback
all the credit and yeah I mean now drew
will do extra thumb exercises on the
side
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports